allons prendre un peu de hauteur avec
des cascadeurs insolite à saint-pierre
décline ses sportifs de haut niveau et
entraînés sont de véritables acrobates
direction le centre-ville à la recherche
de ces gymnastes hors norme
je les ai trouvés
ah oui bonjour les traceurs d'être assez
bien nickel ça va bien un peu un peu
vite mais ça va je suis content tu
réussis à vous trouver c'était pas
évident bah ouais mais généralement la
cantine point de s'être cru l'espace
d'un beau couvert mais la même couvert
il ya plein de partout donc on s'adapte
fabius un peu on fait donc on vous
appelle et traceurs
tout à fait c'est une mode qui a été
lancé par le film yamakasi avec le
groupe les yamakasi quand même bien
popularisé par le par ce film a tout à
fait après youtube youtube a suivi puis
ça ça grossit un peu sur internet comme
ça donc tous ceux qui pratiquent cette
activité ils font ce qu'on appelle le
parcours c'est ça exactement sa
discipline qui porte ce nom là c'est
quoi exactement c'est yahia de
l'acrobatie
le parcours en lui-même c'est vraiment
le déplacement efficace franchir tous
les obstacles tous types d'obstacles le
plus efficacement possible
voilà et après le côté free run ou là on
va travailler plus
l'acrobatie la fluidité la beauté du
geste et la créativité
voilà vraiment deux choses différentes
et le doyen de la bande des traceurs
c'est toi qui a été pendant longtemps le
président de la cc soit là ouais sur
tours ça fait 15 ans que je m'entraîne
donc ouais ça fait ça fait ça commence à
faire un petit un petit moment et puis
j'ai des jeunes qui me suivent sa ba de
de partager sa passion doit faire
découvrir à des jeunes qui pratiquent
juste passionnant sécurité aussi que je
leur donne tous ces conseils là que j'ai
trouvé offert dans les années que je
leur donne pour qu'ils perdent moins de
temps et que finalement la discipline
progresse quoi quand même être un bon
sportif avons une bonne condition
physique
yahia il ya quelque chose qui est dans
ce sport qui est très très très
important a le physique la technique et
le mental c'est vraiment les 3 pour les
trois piliers à travailler au quotidien
la générale garde chasse impressionné
par l'agilité que la qualif il chaud
avec cette rambarde
voilà tu me présente sa bande ouais
carrément donc là dans le fond là bas on
à florian qui s'entraînent sur un
tic-tac passement et puis
duflot excellent ensuite on à martin le
plus jeune de la bande et ensuite on à
al ain si c'est de la danse
ouais ouais bah c'est le côté artistique
c'est vraiment le fun c'est vraiment un
côté artistique on à 110 mabika qui est
aussi mon assistant de l'association qui
s'entraîne depuis un peu plus d'un an et
demi ces deux jeunes recrues voilà tout
à fait voilà donc là on est vraiment sur
le placement de base on est on progresse
tout doucement donc c'est cool ça ça
avance vous dire c'est un score de bande
on ne fait pas tout seul et non ouais
ouais ouais ouais on essaie toujours de
progresser ensemble et on est tous tous
tous plus forts dans un dans un autre
domaine qu'un autre et on s'entraide
comme ça et on progresse ensemble comme
ça c'est qu'il plus jeunes dans la bande
l'as partant
yes
tlf et jeunes toi t'as quel âge 15 ans
et qu'est ce qui te plaît dans cette
discipline
bah c'est bouger c'est vraiment voir
vraiment se confronter avec des gens sur
les capacités physiques et toujours au
maximum
c'est ça qu'il faut ici ça commence à
quel âge j'ai constamment réparé par des
stages puis puis je me suis inscrit
ensuite c'est ce qui me plaît toi ça
c'est partir comme ça être libre ouais
ouais c'est vrai liberté à utiliser
mobilier urbain pour pour en faire parce
que je crois tu es un dieu j'en ai bien
suivre un entraînement savoir justement
qu'est-ce que tu apprends aux jeunes qui
veulent nous rejoindre
écoute ça tombe bien à l'entraînement
dans une demi heure là on va pouvoir
aller là ça donc notre parcours parc au
premier chef de débutants débutants
j'espère me bien sûr bien sûr ah bah ça
tombe bien c'est le rire débutants
[Musique]
allez on est là je vous explique
l'atelier numéro un
[Musique]
donc là on va faire le saut de détente
un pied un pied sauté deux pieds natha
juste à se concentrer en l'air il faut
que tu mettre les pieds ensemble ok
excellent très belles pointes de pieds à
dire à vous les gars comme deux filles
3000 tous ces hommes là il ya d'autres
assos de culture française
qu'est ce qui vous plaît bah le fixie un
sport étaient parents quand tu leur as
dit que je vais être une future yamakasi
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit
[Applaudissements]
bon enfant les passe-muraille bientôt
pour l'instant ils ont fait que des basm
en additionnant qu'ils ont hâte de
chercher
[Musique]
bien fait au fur et à mesure des années
on va faire un dépassement de plus en
plus compliqué et puis ça donne ça
[Musique]
ouais ça fait plaisir ça c'est la grande
fierté c'est vraiment 15 ans
d'entraînement mental technique physique
est ce qu'on arrive à se poser des
limites parce qu'on joue les petits
jeunes et ici ils ont qu'une envie c'est
de passer à l'atelier suivant à
augmenter la difficulté est ce que tu as
tu arrives à te contre un drap ou pas
ouais en fait le défi de trottoirs la
peur toujours la peur qui est présente
même au bout de 15 ans tu as peur est la
peur et friend en permanence donc un
moment donné quand tu es vraiment sûr à
400% que ça va passer
battu mais la peur de côté même si elle
est la cc de la jetée vraiment mais
c'est très très dur mentalement surtout
à 30 ans parce que à moins 15 ans un peu
plus fou mais à 30 ans à la peur et elle
est vraiment décuplée hélas pour la
mettre de côté faut vraiment avoir une
confiance
ultime en sont ces techniques quoi moi
et je reprends l'entraînement
j'aimerais j'aimerais bien arriver à
faire comme tu fais là la keith rabois
c'est une passion ainsi tu sais ça le
passionne et j'en suis non attendez je
monte mon félins à moi m'ont fait là à
moi attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]